hello everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio at San Diego Comic-Con
2023 I am beyond thrilled to be with
some of the team behind the Continental
because
your show is exceptionally well done I
couldn't believe when I got I mean mere
minutes we're going to touch on a
specific scene that comes up at the
beginning of episode or part one once I
got to a specific staircase fight scene
that's like the thing that kind of took
my breath away and solidified that I was
in for something that was above and
beyond my original expectations for the
series so congratulations to you all
thank you I mean it I mean it Marshall
I'm going to start with you here as the
EP on the show I am very curious about
finding the right to direct we're gonna
make Marshall talk about you right now
I'm sorry but the right two directors to
lead this project because the film
franchise is so heavily defined by
Chad's style so what was it like finding
two leaders in that respect that would
continue that style but also make it
uniquely their own as well well that is
a great question but it's it would be
for Thunder Road and Lionsgate because I
came on because Albert asked me to come
on which is a great answer Marshall
because I needed help
[Laughter]
what happened was they they approached
me was Bowser ironic and Erica Lee the
producers of the film series
um that did a zoom with me and at first
I didn't think I would be interested and
then I started thinking about things
like Tony Gilroy and Andor and John
Favreau and Mandalorian and Noah Hawley
and Fargo and I go oh you can kind of
make something and that in a sandbox
that already exists and that it took
place in the 70s
so I go this can be fun and then when I
got on the ground
got introduced to all these guys but I
had to bring Marshall in because I
needed desperate help because it it's a
very complex show as you can see
especially when you're dealing with a
period it's kind of a period piece you
know so I'm gonna flip that idea around
now so you could sing Marshall's Praises
you said you brought her in because you
needed her what is it about her is it as
a producer and collaborator that you
appreciated and thought would serve your
work well good question because I'll say
that about everything we called her the
glue me and the showrunner Kirk Ward who
is my partner in crime she had her
tentacles in every Department there's
certain scenes that I look at I remember
telling her last year ago you produced
every element in that scene and you know
the one scene I'm talking about there's
a monkey in it there's a horse in it
there's air listening to like every
element of that scene she uh diligently
and like went to town working hard on
right so that's her specialty is uh
non-stop going hard right then you have
larnell our stunt coordinator our Action
Unit director who comes from the 8711
world with Chad and David and know that
world and know those guys very well and
know their style right I'm going to
introduce them all and then tell them
what I think their specialty is okay and
then uh and then you let them talk and
then um
the genius uh Ron Rosen who I've worked
with before is not one of the best
editors I've ever worked with he is the
best editor I've ever worked with and
he's a real genre movie Freak and he
loves John Wick so that's great then
Drew Boughton okay my production
designer who just did amazing things
that blew us all away like there's
things you've seen in episode three that
show up at the end right
um that the crew just was like just shut
down and we're in Silence about for 15
minutes so I got very lucky to have all
these people because they say it takes a
village but sometimes the village is
like messed up it don't work out I got
lucky so
so many follow-ups to this I'm going to
start back and get into specifics for
each of you so you get brought in to be
the glue and have your hands and every
element of this production is there a
single thing in the script that you're
like I'm gonna have my work cut out for
me here like it's going to be hard to
pull this off but we'll do it well I I
will now talk about Albert who the whole
the whole reason that you want to work
with Albert is that he loves to
challenge himself and he loves to and
then therefore that challenge is
everybody who works on it so basically
everything has to be done in the way
that the movies were done in the 70s and
that that was the great filmmaking and
he is a wonderful filmmaker he's been
doing it since he was 12 years old so it
just makes it even though it's hard
every day it makes it fun
and challenging and what would be the
hardest one
what do you think the helicopter that
monkey Marshall the monkey there should
be a documentary on getting the monkey
in the opening sequence where Frankie
Goes to introduce himself to correct I
would watch that documentary happily
yeah
I want to talk about the monkey go ahead
no
Albert and larnelle I'm going to throw
this question to you to get at some
specifics here and I feel bad asking
this because it's kind of asking you to
play favorites with your characters but
going into filming this show which
character were you most excited to
capture but then on the other hand which
character wound up being more creatively
fulfilling to work with than you ever
could have imagined Does it include
stunts or non-stunts both I want both I
want both perspectives well that's
actually a really original question and
I don't even have an answer for it I say
I was surprised by what he did with
certain people that we thought maybe
wouldn't get there and then by the
second episode there was a really
amazing fight in an El Camino
by this the wonderful actress Jess
Elaine right because she was a little
tentative and she heard a stunt man one
day and you know she was really
emotional about it and narrow telling
her like no no this happens all the time
you know so it was a little worried but
by time we got to the El Camino I'm like
whoa and then we have to give him the
challenge of something that Kirk Ward
and I always wanted the showrunner when
everybody says this thing an analogy it
was like watching a fight in a phone
booth
larnelle we need to fight in the phone
ding ding all right um
favorites I'm going to say expectation
wise a lot of pressure was placed on
Frankie
expectation wise he starts us off he
makes sure you tune in get you excited
to give you a taste of what's to come
surprisingly I'm going to say the twins
probably were my favorites because thank
you okay now you help me you help me
yeah the Twins were my favorites because
as much as they were silent their
actions and every little thing Albert
captured spoke loudly so that added
pressure to make sure that there was
some payoff when it was time for them to
be physical with anybody and they went
above and beyond with these small things
that will stay and will stand out
compound question you're away right now
because there are just so many hugely
ambitious fight scenes in this going
into filming which did you think would
be most challenging and then ultimately
was it the most challenging or did
something else Catch You by surprise
before you start you know it was
shocking to me you thought one was the
the what do you call it like the crown
jewel
and it ended up being another one that
people thought was the Crown Jewel was
interesting to me but I'm not going to
say which is which you know what I'm
talking about though right yes
yes yes night three yeah because there
was a challenge of
of out topping yourself and not
overstaying your welcome in two
different sequences but the characters
their fights were so different it was
hard to compare but you have no choice
but to compare because they happen back
to back
but the way we filmed it there was the
pressure because I feel like in any
fight sequence your Finale Fight can
determine how people feel overall on
what they've witnessed throughout the
whole series because you're going to
have these feel-good feelings about what
you just saw was there to pay off in was
it worth my time and uh I think where
that fight ended up the last fight I
don't want to spoil anything but I think
we we accomplished our mission because
that was a huge relief off our shoulders
once we saw certain people get down and
uh yeah you come up to two females yes
yes okay yes well what's interesting
about that is like me and him would
always have a conversation about the
thing he said overstaying you're welcome
right then
he did the first edit of of the fight
sequence uh Ron Rosen right I maybe
touched two frames on that it hasn't
changed since his edit right Drew I got
to give him credit for being in a
meeting one day and fighting for the
rooftop build yes because every movie or
TV show has budgetary problems and then
we got to cut this we gotta cut that
whether you have 200 million or five
million there's always cuts and he just
put his hand up one day he's like we
have to do the rooftop we have to do the
rooftop and I was so happy you did it
because by that time Kirk Ward and I the
showrunner were beat down and we kind of
were throwing the towel in so had he not
built that rooftop
but that's also because everyone trusts
him so much because he would always
deliver on budget everything and so if
Drew said I need this you were going to
get it for him
oh I have so many follow-up questions
Ron I'm coming your way first because I
want to talk about a very specific fight
scene that we see at the beginning of
night one it's it's the Wonder in the
stairwell I'm so curious to hear about
something like that from your
perspective when you read a script and
know a fight scene is captured in a
winner like that what are some of your
top priorities as an editor that you
know you need to convey to the team on
set to make sure you could pull that off
so much of this has been
work before I've ever been involved with
the project and I came to this project
as like everyone else was the fan the
John Wick movie saw them all in the
theater the first time watched them
again at home repeatedly but that
staircase yes there was stunt this and
they had worked it out with and on video
with stunt performers beforehand but um
seeing the dailies come in that day and
seeing the skills of uh the actor who
plays Frankie
um it blew me away I was I was so
impressed and so excited to get my hands
material that like that but you know who
wasn't happy
my was cutting at home my dogs would
love to sleep on the couch next to me
they got wind of what I was doing with
that scene they fled that room and they
never came back for a year and a half I
feel like that's a sign of a really
successful fight at it though and he
also hurt my feelings early on in the
end and I go what's your favorite scene
in episode one he was like the staircase
but I go
from the mind of Albert Hughes
everything
it probably is one of the most memorable
fight scenes I've ever seen I I'm
obsessed with Runners I just love that
format and how it can enhance an action
set piece but like in in particular and
like your actor's level of skills in
that it just feels so visceral where you
feel every single punch land as well
it's very impressive well just to play
collider that's a great compliment that
is a great compliment and that's the
dreamy Ben Robson who so good is now can
be a stunt person as well as an actor
which was his goal from working on the
show and working with Hornell I could
see that I want to stick with that scene
for for one more question for you Ron
because the other thing I'm curious
about when you're editing a Warner is
figuring out when to break the Warner
format and make perceptible Cuts how did
you pinpoint the right spot to do that
in well there are a lot of invisible
Cuts in in that sequence that um so it
looks more of a like a runner than it
really is in fact and they did have to
shoot at piecemeal just for safety's
sake and performers can only do so much
before it gets dangerous they can't
ad-lib all that so it was so well
designed and that came from these two
guys right here but also it's a very
deceptive one or the beginning of that
sequence starts out as a like let's say
the the sequence was 100 percent
sixty percent of it's a winner okay then
it starts breaking off into more
traditional kind of a little sequence
wonders
the funny part about that sequence is
then the kind of struggle we would
always have creatively a good struggle
was oh larnelle and this is what 8711
does in which Chad and David do it's
like they don't ever under design
anything it's always over design with so
many ingredients you can start to pull
away some if you want what most people
don't know is there's a whole staircase
sequence we cut out there's another
level like a video game we took one
level out because I told larnell I
thought I'd go you guys are doing all
these wonderful things
this thing that we cut out is so good it
undercuts all these other things
um and I forgot what it even was but
yeah too much of a good thing
well no the team look
um Mikey Roger Hank uh Roe J uh
everybody had their hands in it and you
know the great thing about it is like
what Marshall what I remember is
normally most producers don't allow the
stunt team to go to the locations until
it's finished until it's time to shoot
but to help us prepare they let us
actually stunt viz the sequence at the
location so any room for error was
eliminated and I'll let you know a
little secret we filmed that sequence in
one day
and not in under 10 hours yeah because
we were so well prepared so well
rehearsed the teamwork was on point
um yeah and I had to ask for maybe two
minutes of overtime to get my final shot
in yeah yeah as though I wasn't already
impressed enough
all right Drew I'm coming I'm coming
your way I feel like we could sit here
all day talking about every single set
in this series I am not allowed to keep
you here all day so to highlight at
least two things what wound up being the
most ambitious build of the bunch but
then can you also isolate like some
really small detail that might not be
front and center in a frame but you put
a lot of work into and it just winds up
fleshing out the world in ways that
people might not realize sure
um the the biggest build was the
exterior of the Continental which was uh
a huge set it's about 40 feet tall and
like two football fields NFL football
fields side by side in its footprint of
construction not like grass or you know
just actual build and so that was an
enormous uh enormous structure but what
was wonderful about it is that we had a
obstacle wrapped you know we had an
obstacle with an opportunity in it and
that was that the building in New York
that had been used refused to let us use
the facade as it had been in the in the
films you've been to emulate it even to
emulate it so we had this opportunity
which is you got to change it you got to
change it for legal legal purposes so
you know because the John Wick world is
is so much about art in all its
different ways about painting and
sculpture and dance
photography but in this in this moment
it's like how do I put the sculptures
you know the kinds of things on this
building so we came up with the idea to
put these Eagles to give a whole new
sort of menacing creative texture like a
secret society kind of vibe to the front
of this building so it was just terrific
and then we we put Eagles in the back
because you know once we started carving
Eagles we couldn't stop it
makes all the sense because she acts
about the little details I know my
question to answer but the chotsky game
Drew's chachki game
unmatched like if you look at cormac's
office just look for the horses little
details like that is what keeps me
coming back for more and more and
re-watches and finding things along the
way I have to let you guys go soon I
want to ask two more questions though
learn Al and one of your answers you
rattled off a whole bunch of names and
it was making me think of this because
you are here right now but there's a
huge team of people that worked on this
show so can you each name someone that
is part of your team or someone that you
worked with directly that you know you
would call an unsung hero someone who
made all the difference in your own work
where I hope you exceed your own
expectations for yourself 100 on great
questions
my heart I appreciate that for me I will
say somebody from production because
they're going to answer for the crew so
Sam Mill who was our production
supervisor coordinator
just
unflappable and helped get everybody in
the country out of the country deal with
a war next door yeah yeah it's the kind
of quality you need in someone like that
Sam Mill is a girl I mean I'm not going
to stop you from naming more people well
mine mine is easy my partner in crime
Kirk Ward the showrunner and writer who
is tireless tireless and he was embedded
with larnell and saw all that stuff in
person because we it was almost like
working with my brother I come from a
partnership one can split up and go over
here I Stay in Maine unit he has to deal
with this craziness in second unit so
Kirk Ward's my hero and I also I want to
say
in in the midst of what's going on in
the industry I think this is wonderful
that we got to do this because these are
actually the unsung heroes
um and they don't get enough credit
um during panels like this it's always
the actors and directors I get all the
glory but these are also my my heroes
I Gotta Give It Up look Roger Mikey Hank
Roar all amazing but I gotta give Mikey
um a lot of props on this he was one of
the fight coordinators very creative uh
with storytelling action design so we
had our own language where we didn't
have to say much and get a lot done
faster but he delivered that shot in the
stairwell that was him on the camera
dropping down into the stairwell and
then that was him at the beginning
coming out getting thrown in his head
got four times yeah his head got slammed
three times then had to go upstairs put
a harness on and then get lowered with a
specific timing where it felt like the
camera became a character for just that
moment where it didn't feel like a
gimmick but you're not describing Mikey
and really what he's a jack of all
trades he actually will shoot he will do
the stunt okay he'll help coordinate and
then he'll go and study I didn't get
while they're moving on to the next shot
and he'll edit the sequence before
they're done with the sequence to make
sure we had it because we're on such a
tight time frame uh there was one real
difficult shot when I only had three
minutes left
he grabbed the camera and got the shout
on First Take
like three minutes left and I didn't
want to cancel this spot because it was
a stitch between the next sequence I was
like I have to get this I have to get
this Mikey get in there you sell him so
well I can't wait to like go home now
and Google every single and I hope I
know what your answer is
Ron well first of all I second Kirk ward
he was a writer show runner and he was
supporting us every step of the way and
was right there but from also from my
team uh Armin gasparian was started as
my assistant on the first episode and by
the end he had moved up to a second
editor and he was so instrumental in in
not only the edit but Sound and Music
and and the glue and post-productions
and he's Armenian he's one of he's half
of one of them I'm half Army one of my
brothers
uh so I'm going to say zuzi kizmarti
lechner who's the supervising art
director and her amazing Hungarian team
really extraordinary so we would
I love hearing about it yeah I gotta add
Kirk Ward back into it because he was
like a he was like one of the boys for
us he fought for time he fought for
rehearsals he fought for anything we
needed we've done the flights yeah yeah
he made sure we got what we needed
whether it was time consistency but he
would come by and actually watch our
rehearsals I'd never seen a writer do
this before he would come by and watch
out process then go back and write it in
the script so that way everybody was
more prepared instead of waiting for a
video which which most Productions do
they see the stunt viz and then there's
meetings about the budget can we afford
this can we do this Kirk said ah I'm
just going to write it into the script
to make sure it's broken down properly
so so important it's important to have
the ability to do that on the spot when
you're filming
um Albert I'll throw my last question
your way and this is the greediest
question I could ask because we haven't
eaten these these episodes haven't been
released yet but I have watched them
obviously and that means I want more has
there been any conversation at all about
doing another maybe three-part series or
any other format about stories that take
place in other hotels around the world
oh that's an interesting question you
didn't even ask for season two you were
just you're building out the Universe I
love the Anthology format and I feel
like more franchises don't explore that
as much as they should I wouldn't even
know the answer to that to be honest
right we know ballerina is coming out
right we know about this project
um they haven't approached me about
anything I guess they don't like me no
um um I'm sure they have plans
um but I guess if I'm thinking in a
business way they wait for the show to
drop and see how the audience take to it
and then they make their plans uh
go bigger or they hear the early buzz
and they get a head start on something
that's already good that too by the way
I just want to on camera give you credit
for the most original questions I've
heard in 32 years 100 appreciate you
saying I love what I do so much and I am
just such an admirer of every single
Department that has to deliver work on
any film or show set and the opportunity
to be able to highlight some behind the
scenes work like we're doing here right
now is just like one of the most joyful
kind of conversations for me so thank
you for being here and for sharing some
of your experience with collider and I
mean it sincerely the bottom of my heart
huge congratulations on the concert
that's all